hey what's up guys my name is the
channel welcome back to the game engine
series so last time we had a bit of a
disaster with the audio so i've double
checked
that we should be okay this time we're
gonna jump right back into the kind of
live programming stuff that we've been
doing lately
which to be honest i've been really
enjoying it kind of almost brings me
back to like the sparky days or
just like the the the old youtube days
where it was just like for fun and
wasn't like my job or anything
so i'm i've been really enjoying it
lately and i'm i'm keen to get back into
this so we're going to continue on with
the content browser stuff
and uh we're going to start implementing
some more kind of functionality to that
and i'm also really kind of curious uh
as to what your thoughts are regarding
what kind of direction we should take
the content browser so i could spend a
bunch of time designing this
and come up with something um that we
can use i mean it doesn't have to be
anything fancy at all
but if you have a particular layout or a
style that you really like and you'd
like to see it here
drop a comment below maybe link to
something i don't know you can always
hit me up on discord by the way
there'll be a link in description below
um and
uh and get in touch there's a game
engine series channel
on that discord server where you can
also share some designs if you're if
you're feeling
like it i know that like a content
browser panel might not be the most
exciting thing in the world
but it might just be cool to get some
input i guess from the community oh
actually another thing you can do is
actually open up an issue on github so
the code will be in the description
below there'll be a link to like the
github page with all of this code you
can also open up like an issue there on
github
uh and then you know paste a screenshot
or you know we can talk about it there
so that actually might be a good thing
to do
let me know if you guys are into that
because it would be fun i think to
involve the community a little bit more
and help them shape the direction of
this engine
speaking of which i actually have a bun
i've been thinking about this game
engine series a bunch
and i have some uh interesting ideas as
to like the direction of this because i
feel like for a while we've been kind of
not sure where to go because obviously
we have hazel like the 3d engine which
is available
for patrons who help support like the
series and everything um and that's kind
of like the fully blown 3d engine
and i don't really want to be
reinventing that as part of the game
engine series because the scope of that
is far too large
um to to make in a video series so i've
been thinking of ways to
to kind of um to kind of get this uh
into a bit more of a fun direction but
anyway let's get right into it so the
first thing i want to do
is we have this weird kind of background
um for these buttons and i think we kind
of
saw last time that this was not this is
not because
um this is not because of the actual
image the image is fine it's a png it's
transparent we've got that alpha channel
there
it's because buttons image buttons or i
guess all buttons and i'm gooey actually
have a background they have a default
background color that's part of like our
colors
for our theme and that's just set to be
uh you know to have an alpha value of
whatever
of one i guess and then it's just this
color so we want to basically
just for these folders um and like files
as well
we want to set those colors to be that
alpha channel to be zero basically
and if we do that then we should
hopefully see the background
of the actual content browser panel here
so let's go ahead and do that so we'll
figure out how to do that so
inside content browser panel which is
coincidentally what is open here
um this is okay so this is us looping
through
all of the directories that we have
inside this directory iterator right so
that's the entire current directory
and then what we've got is this image
button
this is the only like image button that
we're displaying so this is obviously
for both directories and not directories
the only real difference i guess
is which icon we show as well as what
our
action is so if we double click on the
directory it opens the directory
what i want to do is basically see if we
can push on a color
specifically for that image button so i
am gui i think it's like
push style color
and then i'm just going to type in i'm
going color underscore and then see well
there's actually something called button
let's see what what's up here
so if i go to the actual definition
you'll see that there are a bunch of
different colors
and this just allows you to basically
temporarily push
a color that you can then pop so instead
of actually going into the style
changing it and then sending it back
which i think you can do as well
this is just a little bit more kind of
temporary in a way because you don't
have to worry about setting it back you
can just pop so you don't have to get
the
current value and then set it to
something else and then set it back to
that
that kind of temporary value um so i'll
just set this to like zero i don't know
if there's a constructor that just takes
in a single scalar value
does not look like there is so zero
zero zero and zero
if i can type um and then i'm just gonna
do the button and then i'm just gonna do
a little pop
so pop style color
uh and then yeah that that's it so
hopefully if that works correctly
man look at me with all the discord swag
just notice that's a coincidence i just
like this cup that they sent me
anyway um so uh yeah that that's it
um i've left the highlight i kind of
like the highlight i think the highlight
is cool
but we we no longer have that background
we can just see through it so that's
kind of cool i think
um now the one thing i want to focus on
today and talk about today is going to
be i'm going related yet again this is
like almost like this i'm gooey series
now
but basically what i want to do is we
currently
if we want to load a scene we have to go
file open
right it opens up here we go assets
scenes
and like 3d example for example that's
uh pink cube is what i want that's
that's the right one i was like that's
not my scene that's not my favorite
scene
um and then obviously we can kind of uh
you know go through this scene and
it's not really a cube but anyway um and
there's certainly no lighting on it it's
just colors
but uh what i want to be able to do is
just click and drag
that into here into the viewport right
so this is going to be a little bit of a
tutorial on how to use i'm goi's drag
drop functionality
so if i go back here it's all pretty
simple in fact
um i think it's called like and i'm not
i'm not copying from any codes this is
going to be somewhat live but
basically as far as i know
there's a function called like begin
drag drop or something right so i can
just use
visual assist there to try and find it
begin drag
drop and i'm going being nice like they
are they have
uh basically where they have all their
functions right they have their drag and
drop functionality
i am on a slightly older version of
imgui i really need to update it and i
probably will next time i'll probably do
that off camera
unless you guys want to see it just
because it's a bit boring i guess
just updating the sub module nothing
there's not much to it really and then
making sure everything compiles
obviously
but basically um as far as this goes we
have all the functions for drag drop are
in one place
and they have comments right so we can
we should be able to take a look at this
without having to look at like the
references
even though again i've always said this
but i'm gui demo
is a fantastic resource for how to use
anything so you can see that like i mean
what i would probably do unless you're
sure that you know what you're looking
for
is open up the like show the actual demo
window then find
like what area you care about what looks
good what functions like you want it to
function
and then like find a string that's like
kind of being used there
search for that string inside this file
because everything that is inside the
i'm going demo window is inside this
like 5000 line of code file
right so you can always do that but then
also so there is actually like a drag
drop example there
which you can use um uh as a reference
to see how it's actually implemented
so you can see there's like begin draft
drag drop target then there's um
end drag drop target and then we have
these ability to accept certain payloads
so there's a bunch of um stuff that we
can
explore there if we want to but let's
have a go at just
using these functions because i think
they're pretty straightforward so we
need to call begin
a drag drop source hard to say harder to
say than it is to write this whole
part probably so a call when the current
item is active if this returns true you
can call set drag drop payload and end
drag drop source so it's a bit of a
tutorial right here in the comments
so um as far as the setting drag drag
drop payload
type is a user defined string maximum 32
characters so that's what type is right
that's the first parameter
uh string starting with underscore
reserved for drm
internal type so we shouldn't use an
underscore to start it data is copied
and held by i'm gui
okay so the way that this works
basically is we begin drag drop source
after we we uh
render some kind of ui element so after
we have our image button
we're going to call begin drag drop
source like with an if statement
then we're going to if that's true
inside the body of the if statement
we're going to call set drag drop
payload
to be basically the path of whatever it
is we're dragging
we're going to give it a name such as
like content browser
item i don't know content browser item
path maybe because i think the payload
is going to
like the type is what we use to accept
the payload later and the payload by the
way is just
some data that's all it is uh and then
inside they have sam and we'll also call
end drag drop source that's the whole
source
side of the things i think that's pretty
much it and then i think we can also
like
um this uh i think there's like a way to
specify i don't know where that is
though we can actually specify
the string of text that's being dragged
oh here we go so if you stop calling
begin dragged off source the payload is
preserved however it won't have a
preview tool tip
so currently we call we fall on this so
we can set a tool tip
um but that's something if you stop
calling begin drought drop source why
would i stop calling that though
um anyway i'm assuming this this
actually called this does something and
then there's
a bunch of drag drop flags as well so
for example no preview tool tip
but i'm still not exactly sure how to
set the tool tip so
we'll take a look at that because again
this does not take a tool tip
so i don't know we'll see and then
that i think is pretty much it or maybe
it will just be or
the item that's being dragged will be
anyway we'll see
so let's just go ahead and try it out at
the very least we'll just do the
um uh like the start of the drag drop so
if
i am gui begin drag drop
source uh we won't use any flags for now
i don't know if we'll have to
um we'll do end drag drop source
and then i'm going set
drag drop payload the type we'll call
this like content browser
item again we should probably store this
in some kind of ui class but we'll
figure it out later
um and then we set the data so pointed
to the to the data now imgui did
actually
say that they copy it so
um data is copied and held by i'm gui so
you have to be a little bit careful with
what you're copying here we don't want
it to be too large
but also we know it's been copied so
that's great we don't have to worry
about its lifetime basically and if it's
a pointer then we can
just copy the pointer if we want so what
are we actually going to copy here
so basically at this point in time
what i could do is just get the current
directory
and remember since we have an asset path
which is assets
we don't need to worry about the full
absolute path or anything like that we
know this is coming from the content
browser
so this is clearly going to be relative
to the asset directory because the
content browser shows the assets
directory and that's it
so i'm happy to basically just say we
don't need any kind of relative path oh
sorry we don't need any kind of like
absolute path
that is this we can just use the
relative path now that is an scd file
system path
um what i can do is from that
i can probably just say that we want
a string from it so we'll get it to
create a string for us so this will be
um std string uh
i don't know item path equals relative
path dot
string right and then i'm going to say
that we're going to basically i mean
this might as well just be a const char
pointer actually
i think that might be something better
to do
but i'm not exactly sure how this works
because
uh sorry let's go back to this
so string w string u8 string we really
should use unicode
there is c string but that's probably
going to be value type which is a wide
string
do i care about that because
yeah this is going to be
this is going to be let me just quickly
go back go back and see
it's important this whole string
situation yeah so
if we if we ask it for a string it's
going to convert
the white characters to non wide
characters
otherwise okay okay so what we'll do i
think
is we will just use c string and it will
use value type with
which is w charty not the best situation
but
um i think we'll do that so basically
this is going to be the item
path right it's going to be a pointer
and this is going to be basically
as far as i understand it should just be
that so value
value of type cannot be used to initial
rk uh
does it really want us to use value type
because it might not be a
wide string it's clearly going to be a
wide char though
like for all cases it looks like
although this is the windows
implementation
but it's a maybe because it's const
yeah some of these error messages
sometimes like they make you think that
it's the wrong type but it's not the
wrong type it's just because const
literally is a different type so if it's
if this is returning const and you're
not setting const it's wrong
so just keep that in mind um but
basically from here
we can just set that up now again um
we're going to revisit strings in the
future
for now we'll just keep it because i
don't really like to use
wide chars but uh that's what we'll do
for now so
the data is going to be item path right
and then the size here is basically
going to be
whatever length that is which um
does sterling work with white characters
no it doesn't
see this is why this is why everything
is a disaster when it comes to strings
because
i don't know how big this is now um and
i can probably ask it
but like that's annoying and why chars
obviously
are two bytes instead of one and so it's
just a bit of a disaster like honestly
though
what am i supposed to do here um
so i i could i guess i could ask it for
the string
but that's wrong as well because that's
going to do the conversion
so i could i can just use
yeah okay string type like that i could
use like that or i could ask for native
which gives me a const
string reference so if i do native dot
size then i will know this is the worst
but also keep in mind
that if you do it this way you have to
somehow encode
the size somewhere right because we
don't know how big this is this is a
disaster to be honest this whole i
i regret this entire operation um i
think
what i'm gonna do instead honestly is
create some kind of buffer
to just contain this because the
well maybe maybe this is worth showing
just for fun
is it fun though i don't think this is
fun this is not fun
i'll do it anyway okay
so we we have a bunch of wide charts we
don't know how big they are
right now this should be null terminated
i expect like any other string again
it's up to this because at this point
it's just a buffer of memory
null terminated cts
what is that i have to google that
this is we're going down a rabbit hole
here
okay null terminated character type
string that's what this stands for
wow okay i did not know that acronym
that's ridiculous just write the damn
words
anyway um so we return this
so the internet stopped by okay so this
kind of says to me
that to be fair we don't need the size
right if we wanted the size we could
have it we still need the size so that
we know how much to read
but also is there a quick easy sterling
for
wide charts because then we could just
use that instead
um and maybe there is i'm just googling
stuff on this monitor this is the live
coding
stuff that we just love so yeah there is
i think there's something called wcs
len why is this what is what is it what
is this function
is this a real function or is this like
a windows function
it's a real function it's a c function
okay so c
strings library my face is very bright i
know from the white light
um so returns the length of a wide
string that is the number of
non-null white characters so this is not
in bytes it's in characters
um and yeah we can see what that is
here um that's fantastic okay so we'll
use that
we'll use that because i don't want to
do i don't want to go down that rabbit
hole and we'll probably use this on the
intercepting side potentially
we will see but um what that tells me
right now and is there like some kind of
yeah there's a white string copy if we
need it okay cool
i don't really use y strings that often
to be fair
um u8 kind of strings are usually the
way to go
anyway so the string will be um item
path
now this is in bytes so it's going to be
times size of
w char t right
uh after that we have cond condition or
something i don't actually know what
that is so i'm going to
take a look at this i'm going to get rid
of this like brightness
there um yeah condition for many set
functions okay i actually don't know
what that is
let's go and find uh the enum
so none always wants first okay this is
interesting
i don't know what this is no condition
same as always set the variable once per
runtime session ah
i see so this is just so that you're not
i guess continually copying the data
because that i guess every frame would
be bad right so is that what this is
so condition has to be either always or
once and if it's always then i guess
you're copying it every frame otherwise
yeah you're not because of the data
frame okay yeah so we should probably
set this to once that's a good point
actually i didn't really think about
that
i am going condition once
um and that's it so if we launch this
right now what we should see is
hopefully no crashes because we're not
accessing memory that
we shouldn't be accessing and also we i
guess we should be able to click and
drag stuff and we are
right now again it doesn't show up like
it shows up
in a weird like you can see that we're
dragging because
there's this little uh like square that
appears there
there is no tool tip i'm not exactly
sure how we can set
um the tooltip uh like how does it
how does it actually how does it set
the tooltip do we have to use begin drag
drop target customer
that's target accept drag drop payload
i'm not sure
we'll we'll get to the tooltips later
now though we should be able to
write the opposite so begin drag drop
target instead of source to intercept
the data
and i want to do this in the viewport so
back in editor layer i expect
if we search for our viewport which is
right over here like i'm happy to get
the whole viewport to just be the
selecting thing but really remember the
viewport is an image
so we basically have like inside the
viewport we have an image and that's
really kind of where where we want to
drag stuff to i think so
it's probably going to be if i am going
after that image which is our whole
viewport
right we're going to do begin drag drop
target now inside here there's no
there's nothing here so and drag drop
target there's no parameters i mean
and then we're going to do accept drag
drop payload now we're going to go back
we're going to copy
content browser item because that's what
we're accepting
we can probably accept multiple types i
imagine um and then we have drag drop
flags which we will ignore
right so what this gives us back is a
const i'm gui payload pointer
that's our payload so from here we
should be able to access our data so
we've got a member called data
we've got an integer which is the size
and then we have some internal stuff
that we don't care about so it's just
really
the data on its size right so we know
that we are going to be
accepting some w char pointers right so
this is
effectively the path right it's going to
be payload
uh dot data like that
uh this is a pointer so we can use the
arrow operator and we will cast
this into the right type because it's a
void pointer
and then now i know the size but it's
not
i guess we are storing the size so i
could use the size
but i also don't have to because it's a
w char
and to be honest like i i feel like i'm
regretting this whole thing because this
w chart is not only not really
renderable
by i'm gui but it's also going to be
we're going to have to just convert it
to
a non-w char to pass into most of our
functions because we don't we don't want
it to be in that format
so this is a disaster of an episode to
be honest
um because i should have just not been
fancy and just use a normal char
not that it's hard to fix but um it's
just that the thing is if we think about
where this is going at the end of the
day
right this is going to do open scene
um which at the moment our open scene
function
opens a dialogue right so here's what
i'm going to do i'm going to go into
this open scene when i duplicate it and
i'm actually going to
have a we'll say a file system
we should be able to pass it into this
actually we'll have a
const file system path path like that
this is going to be the actual function
that does the opening
so in other words if i yoink that and
put it here
this is just going to call this and it's
going to call
it with file path like that which will
construct a path and then we can use
that here
now what do we give it here um to
deserialize we can just give it
path.string
right so there's a few conversions
happening but we will probably
consolidate this whole file system api
and just use parts everywhere in the
future
so that's fine since we are happy to be
cpos plus 17 and above
so that's what we'll do and then this
way we can just
take in a path and hopefully this will
just work because it'll be an implicit
constructor that constructs our std file
system path
from our wide char so this should maybe
work
which is pretty exciting uh and you can
see that's really all there is to it so
let's just hit f5
and see if we can actually grab our
pink cube scene and drag and drop it
into the viewport so i'm pretty scared
because i don't know why i'm scared to
be honest it's a bit lame
let's just drag this oh we already get
an exception okay so payload data is
upset
payload is null content browser item
why is that null content browser item
so payload is just full on null pointer
but i've definitely set it haven't i
so if begin draw oh well it said it once
does that mean
should it not be once but i'm still
dragging it
so what's the point of that then right
okay and flags
so if you stop calling it which i'm not
the payload is preserved however and
have a preview tool tip which will fall
back on this and what are our drag drop
flags
allow null id
our image have no unique identifier to
be used uh we might have to use this
actually for peaking and inspecting the
player before delivery
except my preview tool tip there's a
bunch of stuff here
um let's go ahead and uh but then again
this would have fired this would have
said i'm in release mode what am i doing
why am i release mode let's go back to
debug let's actually try again i want to
see if we hit this assert
because that will just make sure that it
actually is
uh like not working because of um
i'm gonna have to restart visual studio
you know how it is that's hazeldev
ah man i am terrible at this
and i've already got hazel dev open i
think on another screen so it's probably
going to be upset with the whole like
okay whatever how was your day today
what's
your what's your day good yeah this is
it being upset about the database being
already open
yep let's uh wait
has is has it not opened yet have i
closed it again
what is going on i'm not cutting though
i'm not gonna cut this is this is it
this is the new
the new cherno the new downfall of
cherno and any kind of good content
so um let's go ahead and in debug mode
let's take a look whether or not um
[Music]
we can actually see if that assert gets
hit or not meaning that we are trying to
drag something which has a null id which
i guess won't work
so um that's what i suspect is happening
that's probably why the drag drop
payload is null
but uh i guess we can check it out
no well it didn't assert actually so
i guess that's not the reason
is it this once thing
but i don't want to keep setting the
payload that's a bit annoying isn't it
and it's still null
begin drag drop source item path
relative path c string
let's go ahead and just double check to
see what's going on here
i can try drag that so item path is that
i guess we're going to set it here
content browser item
we don't have a condition on it let's
step into this
so condition is always
okay
data frame count is minus one the so the
payload does get copied
into so what's the so payload is drive
yes it's just a global thing right
so the payload should just remain
and it's global so that is
kind of bizarre as to why
wow
is that how we're supposed to call the
target
okay so i'm gonna pop into demo this was
supposed to be easy
yeah so if target then we can just
accept the payload
and then obviously for payload it's just
like a string or whatever they're using
some internal thing which they said not
to use
in the demo but yeah it's just oh
if payload oh so it can be null
because in this case you can see that
there i
only do maybe for a couple frames it's
null or something weird
that that's a bit i would not have
expected that to
because why would target be true then
because the drag drop is active it's
false
okay well let's try that so
we'll basically just wrap this whole
open scene situation
in an if statement to make sure that
payload is not null
and then if payload isn't null then we
can use it so that way we're not trying
to do something weird so let's try
that we'll get rid of our break points
uh okay that may have been better
oh it is better except i don't know what
happened with the null termination
character
ah it's paw i didn't copy the null
termination character okay
never mind so we actually want to also
access the null termination character
which um i mean we we know that that's
just going to be an extra two bytes
so well let's just do string length
plus one and then we'll do that so now
we should get that anyway everything is
working now so turns out the problem was
that the payload
can be null even if it's accepting a
drag drop payload
oh sorry even though even if it's
accepting the drag drop target so that's
fun but if we drag in the pink cube now
i was really hoping that would work uh
yeah that seems legit okay
so the last thing we have to do though
is make sure that we patch it with the
assets path
so at the moment unfortunately as i
mentioned
we inside content browser panel we have
hard-coded this
assets until we have projects
introducing projects probably going to
be something i'm going to do soon
so what i'll do for now is i will
actually
uh and this is where conde browser
pattern is inside hazelnut okay
what i'll do for now is i will change
this to just be a global
right and then that way i can just grab
this and put it into
this is very temporary right but i'm
going to put it into like editor layer
and it's just going to be this is inside
hazelnut space yeah i'm going to just
mark it as a next turn
but this is just going to be that global
asset path so now what i can do is just
join the two together
so when i do open scene what i want to
do is basically
asset path slash path so i'll have to
make this a file
system path so we're going to do asset
path and we're going to combine
that with that and that should be okay i
think
because every time that we open a scene
now um unless it's
and this is we'll talk about
consolidating all these file system
paths and stuff in the future because
this is going to be something that
really does need to be
taken care of early on unresolved
external symbol are you
for real how okay so in a
const variable declaration next time
must be applied to all declarations
in all files
global const oh i did not even know that
so i think we have to mark this as
x10 as well is that going gonna work
yeah okay well there you go i don't even
know c plus plus no one does
all right so back here
uh pink cubed hazel please work
yes we did it okay so we can now just
drag
any scene we want
can we not open more than one scene
maybe we have to close
the scene that's weird
why can't we drag more than one scene in
i was excited
it always opens pink cube
why is it always opening pink cube
begin drag drop source
i wonder if because these should uh
i'm not i i'm pretty sure that if
they're not set to null
like because the thing is these image
buttons images have the same
image and i don't know what it's using
as its id here
because like i have a feeling that the
last item id
is probably going to match i might be
wrong
to be honest because what does it even
because we've had some problems with
hazeldev with
just ids in general right because this
pushes an id and then uses this i guess
but it's
i guess that should kind of work but the
thing is this user texture id is going
to be identical and
that's what i think is going on so
i'm going to try and use drag drop flags
source allow null id but that
might not even work because
maybe we should set an id maybe we
should push an id
we might have to push an id if this
doesn't work
yeah okay so that disregard that
what i'm gonna try and do is for this
entire thing
i'm gonna try and but that might not
even work
okay here's a here's a quick test right
so if i just
have an integer i push id i
plus plus like that
uh and then i pop id does that work
because if that does work then i guess
that'll be okay to to use and it does
okay whoops so now i can um
[Music]
i can load any of these scenes
by just dragging and dropping them in
okay so what happened there
was because these images are identical
they're the same image
and unfortunately images and i'm gui
there is image button ex which lets you
actually specify an id that's probably
what i should have used actually because
i would have saved this
we use this a bunch in hazeldev because
[Music]
otherwise if you have like a bunch of
icons like that
that use the exact same texture id
um in this case in opengl which
obviously you will
if you have like a bunch of folders for
example then you won't be able to
identify
one folder from another and so because
we were rendering three images that were
identical right like if i go back here
um and we take a look at it because we
were rendering
three kind of file icons in a row inside
the scenes directory one two three
they were like overriding the last kind
of thing and so when we tried to drag it
it just went back to the very last one
which was the last iteration of this for
loop and it said that directory
inside set drag drop payload and so we
don't want that to happen so what we
what what we can do instead is push an
id
which basically is like pushing a name
space kind of for our variable name so
if we have three variables called
icon but we push a namespace that's
different for each variable
that's fine and that will work and so
that's actually a legitimate option
or we can use image button ex which lets
us actually specify an id
instead of just assuming that get
renderer id is the id
so i think i'll leave it as as this push
id does not have to be an integer
it can be like a void pointer it can be
a string id
so we could just say that this is a
directory entry
let's use like the path as an id that's
also totally fine
um in fact i think i might do that
instead of having this i
variable i think what i can do is just
direct your entries a path right
i think i can just ask it for
um
[Music]
like i don't want the actual oh no this
is okay directory entry path is the path
so let's let's get the path and then i
can probably ask it for how are we
getting the y
chart before um we're getting it using
uh oh let's just see string okay so c
string
so that's obviously going to be unique
for each directory entry because that's
the actual path of the file
it's going to be unique so we can just
use that as the id
and i think that should work fine that
might be a little bit better so
oh never mind wait what
it wasn't working before now it is but
oh no okay so that's
apparently that's not working even
though they should have different ids ah
but is it
should just be using that string id
everything's the worst so what happens
if we use push id
no keep alive id stack and that i guess
does the same thing for this
yeah that's a bit bizarre that it's not
working
because they should obviously have a
different
address but it's oh
is it going to have a different address
though for each
maybe we should actually use the id
so let's do this
we've got the file name string we can
use that
we'll use the file name string i think
it's just it's messing up
the ids so if we just do that maybe
maybe that will work this is a
um okay let's try this
yeah okay there we go so that works now
and we can drag any of these in
and you can see that we try and load a
scene now obviously we need to handle
if we try and draw you know drag that in
because it's not going to work i guess
it's just going to
clear it which is a bit nice um but uh
and we don't have the tooltips yet but
that's the that's the general gist of
drag and drop in i am gui
and we can obviously now just drag in a
scene to load it which i think is pretty
cool okay
so hopefully you guys enjoy this little
episode and the live coding you can see
hopefully by this episode how difficult
it is to make a game engine i mean
we just spent like 42 minutes trying to
do this one thing um
and i've done it before which is even
worse so
yeah maybe a little bit unlucky with a
few of the problems we ran into
but let me know what you guys think of
this kind of format um i'm enjoying it
i'm having fun hopefully this is kind of
uh interesting to you guys i think
if you're uh if you if you've made it
this far in the series we're like i
think we hit our 100th episode like a
a few episodes ago or something like
that if you've made it this far in the
series i think it's safe to say that you
can continue your own engine and this
series will just be a form of like kind
of
maybe quick tips here and there a little
bit of like a development log
almost of an engine and like more of an
entertainment kind of thing
then it will be a strict tutorial a
step-by-step tutorial on how to make an
engine because that's obviously
a little bit not practical to make and
also
um uh yeah i think it would just be more
valuable
to you if you just you know actually
took matters into your own hands
and continued development with your
engine i don't know if how many how many
people are seriously watching this
series with the intention to just
copy this episode by episode and that's
how they're learning to make a game
engine
if you are that's probably not the right
thing to do um
hopefully the first kind of hundred
episodes or so showed you how to get
started
but then the rest is just about you know
researching features you're interested
in and then adding them in
um that being said let me know what your
thoughts are don't forget you can help
support the series by going to
patreon.com to the channel and get
access to like the real hazel
uh where you know we have all of this
stuff implemented
um and uh there's a bunch of great work
being done there by a bunch of
volunteers from the community
and an employee of mine as well and
myself so
um that's kind of the the gist of what's
going on with hazel
have a great day and i'll see you guys
next time goodbye
[Music]
you